les possibilités qui s'ouvrent en santé
mentale sont passionnants plan ce
psychologue vendredi soir à l'université
mcgill
la conférence sur les thérapies par
hallucinogènes fait salle comble le lsd
la mdm a ou encore la psilocybine
l'ingrédient actif des champignons
magiques sont reconnus pour causer des
hallucinations
mais depuis quelques années les
chercheurs étudient ces substances pour
leur potentiel de traitement de certains
troubles de santé mentale
le psychiatre simon a marre dirige une
étude à montréal qui porte sur le
traitement du choc post traumatique par
la ndm-1 s'il me dit qu'il compte dans
cette étude trois fois le répète sans la
sur place pendant huit heures de temps à
travailler en thérapie pour le milieu il
s'agit d'une révolution une toute autre
approche au traitement faire
actuellement
on s'éloigne de la réduction des
symptômes est en train se dirige plus
vers une guérison plus profonde ou delà
du stress post traumatique et de
l'anxiété d'autres problèmes comme la
toxicomanie font l'objet de ce type
d'étude partout dans le monde
malgré l'illégalité de ces drogues
l'intérêt pour ces thérapies est bien
réelle le chantait montage d'une
communauté qui qui a pas assez de
ressources pour servir le besoin dans
notre société alors une certaine
impatience
mais attention aux débordements
certaines personnes tentent la thérapie
par elle-même une mauvaise idée selon
les chercheurs
j'ai cette même peur que si on commence
à l'utiliser en dehors des contextes de
recherche qui est des accidents des
personnes qu'ils ont de mauvaises
expériences
les psychologues tente de mieux
s'outiller pour aider les patients en
attendant que ce genre de thérapie soit
autorisé à plus grande échelle
c'est possible que d'ici deux trois ans
c'est devienne un traitement a reconnu
et utilisé pour la population générale